what other books yeah okay so hannah
rent
she is a philosopher that not a lot of
people know about
but she was a jewish woman during the
holocaust and she was
in turn interned at bergen-belsen
which was uh basically auschwitz for
women
and she escaped she came to the united
states and she had worked with heidegger
even though he's supposed to be
anti-semitic and
a nazi and everything but they were
lovers okay so she comes out and she's
at columbia university and she teaches
philosophy there
and she writes this she writes two books
which i'll recommend
one is called eichmann in jerusalem
where she attend
attends the nuremberg trials and she
basically makes this really
astute observation about evil and she
says
eichmann is one of the people who sent
the jews to the concentration camps who
ran the trains okay
um and she said the thing about eichmann
was that he didn't seem particularly
evil actually he seemed to be quite
a nice guy she said what was interesting
about him was he seemed
incredibly thoughtless and stupid and
she said and he used a lot of
stereotypes like memes
so she actually wrote about memes before
we had them
and now people just use memes and
they're actually used against us even
there's even a segments of warfare
called memetic warfare
all right so memes are something that
can sway a whole population of people
so she wrote about memes before they
were even in existence
and that's eichmann in jerusalem and i
think she also has some really amazing
things to say about evil
is that um when people
remain thoughtless she has another book
called the life of the mind which is
gigantic and i don't
think anybody will read it but frankly
it's one of the best books i've ever
read
and i've read it many times and
basically the life of the mind and the
life of the mind she asks a very simple
question
she says why do people do bad things why
are they evil
and what she says is she wonders if it's
she says that
bad people sleep well at night contrary
to you know how the saying
how do you sleep at night well that's
only because you're a good person that
you're asking that question
because you actually have a conscience
and a conscience is this dual
kind of you fight with yourself about
the consequences of your actions
and she says bad people don't seem to
have a conscience
so they actually sleep well at night and
so she goes through a whole history of
philosophy
uh about evil and that's really a good
one too but i have um i also have to
recommend this one too there's one more
so i know i recommended two but just
from the same philosopher
uh my friend jeffrey cripel he's at rice
university and he's in my fields right
uh religious
studies he wrote he's written several
books i mean he's written a heck of a
lot of books let's put it that way
but he's um his i think his best book or
the one that impacted me the most
is called authors of the impossible and
his book is
his writing is very much like
nietzsche's writing in the sense that
he it's almost as if he reaches out of
the pages and he grabs you
and he kind of slaps you around and says
think about this you know
and you can't help but be changed after
you've read it and he's got a great
chapter in there about jacques valet
oh so he calls a bunch of different uh
thinkers and authors that
are outs that somehow are what is it
renegade in some aspects of
revolutionary semester they're thinking
the impossible
uh there's a great one he's written
called mutants and mystics
where he talks about uh the comic strips
uh
the um gosh why can't i remember the
name of the person
he just died stan lee he talks about the
history of the comics by stan lee
and they're all paranormal they all
start off super paranormal
and it's fascinating um on the topic of
honor aurent yeah
so i haven't read her work but i've
vaguely touched upon sort of like
commentary of
her work and it seems like some people
think her work is dangerous
in some aspect i don't know if you can
comment on
why that is i just it it feels like
similar with iron rand
or something like that yeah like this is
i should say not dangerous but
controversial yes it is yes they think
it's controversial
um this is the reason i believe um i've
heard of the controversy
the controversy is that she didn't i she
first of all
um she is jewish and she did escape
a concentration camp and yet she's
called
she's been called anti-jewish and i
think part of that was that she
basically was saying
something that i believe
that a lot of normal people
are like eichmann and evil things are
done
by people who just follow the rules and
they don't think about what they're
doing
and that's one of the most pernicious
forms of evil of our time
you